now I want to start
kind of the way that I feel like a
little bit I was introduced to you
um I picked a few videos they're more
recent than I feel like I was part of
the original crew
um but take a look at this video right
now that I'm gonna show okay first of
all how this girl does this she's
unbelievable I know
how did you get the idea to do that one
because I've never laughed out loud so
hard it was it just made my day it made
my year I watched it 15 times in a row
it's usually you know the less they're
wearing and the more they're moving
that's what I'm after well then that's
what I'm after let's look at this next
video for that perfect example
okay this is that couple just so you
know that's not me there I am
I don't know if I speak for any of the
women in this audience but I remember
this moment
I was with my boyfriend and I'm sitting
on the couch you know like eating
Chinese takeout and I'm just letting it
all hang out and on Comes This
Victoria's Secret commercial and the
women are walking out with the thing and
the thing
and I was sitting there like this
um
and I was like in this moment I really
just wish
I looked different yep that moment like
scarred me because I was like
I'm just in my home
and I'm now like working with an
insecurity that I didn't have before I
saw this thing and it just really messed
me up
and that's a moment that really stuck
with me and when I discovered you
I wished in that moment that I had done
what you did
how did you find the answer of life that
way well
I look has never been my main currency I
am I look fine I look great
but who I am my sense of humor my
ability to laugh at myself
is my main currency and I love that
about myself and I find that really
beautiful I find that really exciting I
love being around people who are the
same who and who are happy just kind of
really leaning into what it is that they
have that they put out into the world
and I know that when I'm around people
and I'm in a tiny little bikini and I
don't look like that Victoria Secret
model looks I know that the women that
are around me in that moment feel better
about themselves because I'm comfortable
sitting however I look in something that
is not really made for people who look
like me so I I've always always lent
into my strengths and that is my sense
of humor I'm mainly the whole thing I
wanted first up was for people to laugh
to go oh my God and then laughter is the
greatest equalizer and then you can go
into it how you want so do you think
there's a shift happening yeah I
definitely think there's a shift
happening I I think I'm really impatient
I'm like come on let's shift quicker
like you know still oh there's a plus
size model on the runway shut up just
put her on the runway and don't talk
about it right that's how I feel about
that yeah I'm I'm very impatient action
not word yeah A Little Less Conversation
little more action that's my thing
ironically
um your uh your husband
um you call him hot husband so these
sort of parallel universe to this
conversation is you Adorn him with a
very adorable nickname
um now he's a tree surgeon what exactly
do tree surgeons do they look hot when
they climb trees that's what tree
surgeons do no it's not true just my
husband it looks hot when he does it he
climbs trees and he cuts the limbs and
prunes them and not anymore I've retired
him he doesn't do that anymore he raises
our children but then he did it's hot
it's super hot right I was just gonna
say like what an afro
I just I love it yeah I was always like
oh where is the skinniest Oddball
comedian in the room I'm that's my guy
what is next for you what else do you
want to tackle
um I've got things happening my friend
really yeah that drives me crazy when I
hear people saying that you're like well
tell us I can't or I'll get tasered yeah
exactly yeah no I've got like I've got a
Netflix TV show coming out shut up yeah
I know it's so exciting and I got some
other things so I know I have a question
for you really yes I have a very
important question for you yes
is this the chair
that Keanu Reeves sat in when he said if
you've got if you're not going to fight
for your love what kind of love do you
have is this the chair it's the very
chair oh my God
oh my God oh my God do you know what
this means
do you know what this means that's him
right there everybody oh I thought he
was actually here
let's partner if you come back I will
find a way to produce Keanu Reeves
absolutely not nothing less you have
made my life better you have made the
world better so thank you
thank you thank you so much all right
next hit you can't beat um you can't go
I can't even talk next uh you know what
who cares we're going to commercial bye
[Music]
thank you